[music]
my name is stefan becker sunshine
in a have the cousins conference in mu
ich and innovation in food if we co
p rating will be in berlin switc
es going to take place in november is he
e in berlin a let you like
he corporate it happy to  do
that here via focusing on food and
cities food for thought that i want to
look at the options it innovation in
food and production especially in the 11
[music]
he stood but partys looking into humility in
front of the futures society which is mainly
living  in america this very strange
perspective is tempting aspect if they
just talking you're strange but we think
that we structural change will happen in
cities the song new technologies that
can be added to the environment and we
think that the classic transport vom
food by lernst  and the city is going to
change the medical
[music]
because the karoo situation is the
helper for more than we need more than
the title of the highway to change d  he
lifestyle and as soon as a more money of
the city added herbert different the
costs meeting proteam cent
heyer ready so that is resident big
koblenz is not able to provide that
no no food to people and world as we
have it right now here in the dumpling die
had problem is not in the globe
from the t shirt per cent of post have
is going on - there is lag of
infrastructure to collect food from the
many cents process is therefore can go to
the people was super markets fund so
diestel said karin challenge  and have
to see how des develops fpga cities and
metal positive doping is when the 25
million people living in bonn spot is
a can work together to change the
production system intervene
industrial station before the activity
[music]
countries or continents please is called
glos afrika as well  can expect most of the
challenges in the series us but we have
to think about the globe es aus when
matchballs areas data rosso in need of
it because we have sockel f  ood the
sandvik western cities this food des
not in the prairie us people have
tasted to walk and at least two three
kilometers shares a supermarket the
only way to you by football guests cent
less than said to provide food is in
the series especially in times like us
help auges pandemic wer systems are
working barry hdmi high end peter and
help the money to spend in good food
[music]
the major changes and climate change we
have the days when america with american
city have lots of rain tour end
stranger pianissimo here in  germany like
this would have three jump ropes change
is definitely a problem and will drive
technology is controlled environments
enkel kulture weekend especially
little areas to produce the
independent and small mit and cleans
newsletter water and led lights two to
go in the house pointed in the fr
[music]
corona is prosinger problem to the
geology from a global hosting end
global los like habel lot of job los
the lead to the fac  t that people are not
able to provide family photo look at
american long lines foods and as well i
can pick up for families automatic
situation in the globe from we have
a problem with swear link to the loss
of shots and day center money home to
the families and the country so recognize
at for example sees hellwig robin in front of the front
door of the places
the scotts deliver this live at the
families out in the country so the
local situation where they might not
have a crux of the here
world food program is already have  to
expect at a problem in this
countries in which on 22
and yes hand in the global los many
people austria jobs bed of the closure of
the borders bread in extreme problem in
spreading in the clubs of missing
that is necessary
numbers of crown in some countries  to
gloss so the problem of migrant workers
especially in the area sepa system an
[music]
globi sound is very important to improve
the infrastructure center courts of
befi  ehlt kenobi harvest in the course and
bread intercitys cabaret artists time for
example shanghai meet both pandemic
the working and programs to have gardens
inhouse gardens the just open the
shopping mall and the third floor the
herbert pick drive in the bearded
garden to led and the program like  man
city percent on the foodwatch until the end of
city limits at t shirt so here you can
boils big cities of driving innovation
and change very much ends path of
nature is coming and the city look for
example in the reggae country star
interesting to have production of
protein  except for kevin leisch stoxx so
the basket rating des companies that have
featured or produce pro team
june from seo to end victoria and energy
to provide title of the protein so that is
totally different kind of production that
is not real life stop protein protein
is in different  ways maximo system will
ne na.de base as well as side to the fresh
fresh products the city limits the lot
of technology is avail  able
die just need to know how in
wettcafes fog die instruments den hof fest
[music]
but until may offers as in your heart of
development and driving dies
technologies because many things come
out of our research departments here in
jork europe except implement you have on
the sectors peile project which a 31 in
the european countries
[music]
because as half extremes the
creative class d red lips intercitys the
creative class is the delicacy long
live in cities the styling
biochemistry energy medicine
june with the world brand interest in
changing the  city with natural place we are w
rking on messestädter close to natur
krispl genome editing culture beat asset
before yes definitely and s
ndvik has composer inter
ational companies the fierce resea
ch department day corporate for examp
e to pharm
companies that are calling nutra
euticals so important ports betwe
n medicine sametime  fast food
that's the expectations something with lee in
need o  f having a wife and place to make
this new products possible where it
help in the eu country levels
kaindorf photos dpa
dapd this july it finally concepts
as well as en suite of discussion of the
political either spd where the enemies
of the internet can for any
[  Music]
we fink right now in the face who how
canon bring de fruits of investments
who have been profit in the past and to
50 necessary research and has been
done that is a leading into action
sladky do you know a skin fungus start up
service companies a result  of investment
have already been spent the point where
we have to return on investment facility
of investment face a dervish all the
start of the best of luck to be
successful der product is important
products are going to be accepted both
people who think of product is pushing
the time stamp robbins because i have to
be prepared to something is different
from that my ship is in front of an innovative
foot sends how not too long will
d  as process of implementing innovative
[music]
and how kensy is to new food inventions
innovations- he is developing
no may only live structure because it
can help with instituts aqua cultura
pacific protein production of the culture
beat which is the question what this mean
to global food  supply chain that we have
right now and here the
circle of citizens office angeles to be expected no ossi is ali
from the proven food classic just
the big easy to say we have to topic of
small and local and its watchers time
again shopping mall in shanghai yu
produce  and the third floor is in the
basement have copy for future week
fast innovative projects
we are with the conditions via
planning an event natural history museum it big
is possible and be part of virtual event
beach feeling better and inserts
chamber to cross am ideas and hope that
i will be present at the meeting virtual
personal
this price will not ftops xviii
going to present the plague of
inn  ovation
[music]